the Chinese ambassador to the United
States has said that Beijing has no
choice but to defend itself from a trade
war it doesn't want one started by
Washington it's important to notice who
started this trade war we never want to
have a trade war but if somebody started
a trade war against us we have to
respond and defend our own interests the
remarks come amid heightened tensions
over months of billions worth of
tit-for-tat tariffs between the world's
two largest economies one of the reasons
for the trade war is Trump's anger with
China's trade surplus with the United
States but despite all the punitive
measures America's trade deficit with
Beijing has now in fact reached a new
record a Daniel bushel picks up the
story the supreme art of war is to
subdue the enemy without fighting sanzu
6th century BC applied by his homeland
today to a different war trade wars
protracted trade war labeling of China
as the enemy trade war continues came on
here a trade war between the United
States and China is here it's real China
is accusing the White House of launching
the largest trade war in history
Trump slaps vicious restrictions on
Beijing yet its sales just grow to the
biggest trade surplus with Washington
ever
in other words Beijing has never sold so
much stuff to the states while buying so
relatively little in return America
whacked tolls on China in January next
month Beijing only sells the more same
after fresh US fees in July August and
September
now panic after this month record sales
by Beijing to America
his Trump's plan working or is he just
talking the talk China's market
distortions and the way they deal
cannot be tolerated China has been
attempting to interfere in our upcoming
2018 election I've done a lot of
business with China China China China
China seems rude China
for a long time Beijing also holds a
nuclear option up the sleeve it owns
over a trillion dollars of US debt if it
calls that cash in something Washington
has a problem there are talks for a G
Trump summit next month where a US way
out the Chinese finger trap can be
hammered out till then who'd a thunk it
Trump would make China great again so
what this means is that of course China
is basically won the trade war in this
the first round and and it shows that of
course the American consumers are the
ones that are going to be are paying the
highest prices for this and it's not
harm China certainly the US has no
position of strength going into these
talks but China has done is continue to
emphasize its exports to the u.s.
American importers are rushing very very
fast over the last two quarters to get
as much product and as possible before
the tariffs hit and China is pursuing
other trade relationships to continue to
cause their economy to grow so this what
this shows is that the US has completely
failed
you